[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
People's health,
finances, and daily
lives are significantly
affected by our
ever-changing environment.
As a result, they are
increasingly turning
to their financial service
providers for information about
things like their mortgage,
hours of operation,
credit card payments, auto
policies, and 401(k)s,
using online and phone
support channels.
The sudden, unprecedented
customer demand
is overwhelming customer
support resources.
In this video, we will walk
through a Contact Center AI
Rapid Response Virtual Agent
solution specifically designed
for financial service
providers to help
you address immediate
customer queries
and relieve pressure from
your contact centers.
Let's take a look.
Here is a web-based experience.
Let's say I'm a mortgage
customer looking to refinance.
The conversational
experience returns a guidance
and directs me to a link
where I can start the process.
Now let's try another
example and pretend
that we are a banking customer.
I want to know the
best way to bank
since I'm sheltering in place.
And here I get more info
on drive-up teller windows
and some things like submitting
a check or paying bills online.
If you would like to customize
a solution with your own web UI
to match with your brand,
you can absolutely do that.
Here is an example.
Let's say a user is
interested in finding
the closest open branches.
The chatbot asks for
the user's location
and then responds back with the
three closest options to them.
These responses are
dynamic and are served off
of a backend that
queries Google Maps API
and then returns the
closest locations.
Along the same
lines, say a user is
looking to know their
bank's hours of operation.
The experience asks
for the address
and returns back the closest
bank with the days and times.
The responses are coming
from the same agent.
It just has a custom UI.
Now if you have users
calling in through the phone,
you can easily assign your
phone number to the experience.
We have one assigned here.
Let's call and find out
about credit card payments.
VIRTUAL AGENT: Hello.
How can I help you?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: I will
miss my credit card payments.
How can you help?
VIRTUAL AGENT: If you
want to formally request
that your credit card payment
be delayed for yourself
or your business, then please
enroll online for the fastest
service.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: As you
saw, the open source template
is pretrained with common
financial services-related
questions.
You can enhance and update the
experience as often as needed
through Dialogflow.
Refer to the links below for
a quick guide to get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]